i'm gonna try those upgraded canned  cinnamon rolls that are going viral all  over tik tok getting anxious  [Music]  what  spread these cinnamon rolls out evenly  pour over one cup of heavy whipping  cream now we're making like this butter  sauce one stick of melted butter one  tablespoon of ground cinnamon three  quarter cups of light brown sugar mix  until it's all fully incorporated pour  this all over the cinnamon roll cover  this with foil and bake it at 350 for 45  minutes it's done  oh hot  the last step is to pour on the icing  that came with the cinnamon rolls look  at how beautiful she looks the video  said to scoop up all these buttery oh  buttery icing  oh  cheers  mmm if someone brought this to a party  and said they made it from scratch i  would believe that there's these like  crunchy chewy sides like brownie edges i  literally devoured it it's so good